pour
[Musique]
ce débat a été intense mais pour quelles
conséquences on sait que jusque là les
précédentes confrontations télévisée
n'avait pas vraiment influencé le
résultat dans les urnes
oui effectivement traditionnellement ça
assez peu d'importance et assez peu
d'effet surtout sur les sondages
là notre dernière mesure créditait
emmanuel macron de 60% des intentions de
vote
peut-être que compte tenu de la
spécificité de ce débat et du fait que
ça a pris quand même une tournure assez
agressive assez violente
ça peut avoir un effet l'avenir nous le
dira laurent bouvet à se demander si
emmanuel macron allait tenir le choc
face à marine le pen face à une
candidate réputé bien difficile dans les
débats finalement c'est lui qui a pris
l'avantagé hier soir oui il ya eu un
effectivement une surprise de ce point
de vue là je pense chez l'ensemble des
téléspectateurs puisque on n'avait
jamais vu emmanuel macron dans une
confrontation à intel en avec un tel
enjeu cela dit on n'avait pas vu non
plus marine le pen dans cette situation
donc c'était pour les deux quelque chose
d'inédit et on a vu effectivement il
marine le pen qui avait qui avait a
attaqué je crois que ça a été ça dès le
début elle a commencé en attaquant
extrêmement fort parce que elle est dans
les sondages à 20.2 emmanuel macron donc
ccl d'attaqué et le fait qu'elle attaque
et qu'en face elle se retrouve face à
une défense
effectivement très calme avec quelqu'un
qui est sur les questions économiques
extrêmement compétent qui n'a pas de qui
n'a pas besoin de ces fiches je crois
que cette différence de style dans la
manière de parler à partir de ces
dossiers on avait cette pile de dossiers
devant marine le pen et avec un emmanuel
macron qui devait avoir deux trois
fiches simplement qu'il a à peine
consulter a marqué tout de suite une
différence après sur d'autres enjeux il
a été un petit peu moins à l'aise plus
en retrait on a vu au milieu du débat
sur les questions régaliennes ou là elle
a poussé très fort où lui était sûr de
la politique publique lui elle était
sûre du vraiment de l'incarnation au
sens le plus la plus virulente 1,2 sur
un domaine qui la caractérise et qui
caractérise son parti son mouvement
politique
et puis à la fin on a vu qu'elle tenait
presque plus la distance qu'elle comme
si elle avait lâché prise et elle était
dans une forme de deux elle rigolait de
manière un petit peu moqueuse c'était
pas du tout présidentielle alors qu'on
on a vu un emmanuel macron qui a terminé
en plaçant ses dernières interventions
un niveau de présidentiabilité si on
veut bien plus élevé je crois que c'est
ça pour mon père pour moi en tout cas
les trois moments un petit peu du débat
c'est à tes bras vous êtes d'accord
c'est avec un des enjeux aussi de ce
débat s'est montré cet aspect de
présidentialité des candidats est là
emmanuel macron a marqué des points face
à marine le pen sur cet aspect oui
complètement parce qu'on s'imagine à la
place d'emmanuel macron avoir autant
d'insultés de d'accusation etc
marine le pen a proférées à son encontre
il aurait plus justement sortir de ses
gonds et on s'en dit que marine le pen
attendait justement ce moment là
puisqu'elle a à chaque fois qu'ils
s'énervent et un petit peu en tout cas
qu'il avait un ton qui monte tu n'es
jamais vous calmez vous vous êtes trop
nerveux
vous sentez qu'elle a préparé cette
phrase là pour justement le mettre en
défaut sur cette présidentialisation de
son personnage parce qu'effectivement
c'est un guy mais un nouveau venu en
politique donc les besoins de ce débat
pour montrer qu'il était à l'aise à la
fois sur ces dossiers et puis en même
temps maîtrise de son de son attitude
nicolas lebourg ce débat a été souvent
jugées indignes marine le pen porte
certainement à la responsabilité de ce
débat qui a tourné un véritable pugilat
ça a été rappelé est-ce que c'est aussi
le véritable visage de l'extrême droite
française qu'on a pu voir hier selon
vous il ya deux aspects différents dans
votre question est ce que marine le pen
et front national demeure un parti
d'extrême droite c'est une question
qu'on pose régulièrement oui l'extrême
droite c'est pas une gageure dans notre
vie politique ça existe depuis le 19e
siècle comme formule début 19e
ça correspond idéologiquement lit les
livres de marine le pen on lit des
choses qu'on lisait déjà au 19e siècle
dans ces courants là donc ça y'a pas y'a
pas de soucis sur cette question là ce
qu'on a vu hier c'est une tradition de
l'extrême droite française
le problème par delà c'est que marine le
pen ça fait un an et même plus depuis
les régionales qu'elle sait garder
mauvais reports de voix depuis la droite
qu'elle sait qu'elle a des mauvais vote
sur les csp + qu'elle sait qu'elle
pénètre mal sur le segment des retraités
et c'était tout cela qu'elle allait
chercher elle n'y est pas arrivé dans la
campagne sort du premier tour les stades
que l'on a là nous montre que sur les
retraités que sur les csp + elle n'a pas
progressé
on a eu ce méli mélo sur l'euro la
monnaie commune qui étaient censés les
rassurer et on arrive au débat d'hier
si le débat d'hier lui a permis de mieux
pénétrer les csp + et les retraités j'en
serais extrêmement étonné pour ma part
jérémie mani comment ça a été
vécue par les internautes est ce qui est
un verdict on parlait d'un un gagnant
d'un perdant qu est ce qui ressort pas
ce qui ressort de façon très classique
c'est le fameux biais de confirmation
c'est à dire que si vous aviez
l'intention de voter marine le pen c'est
pas ce débat qui va forcément changer
les choses en tout cas dit autrement on
est tous très nombreux à dire que
emmanuel macron rega nice ce débat là je
peux vous assurer qu'il ya énormément de
militants sympathisants front national
qui considère que c'est marine le pen
est à gagner sans trop donner
d'arguments derrière mais qu'elle
considère néanmoins une fois que ceux ci
a été dit on constate quand même qu'il
ya un certain nombre
difficile à chiffrer de sympathisants de
militants front national dont le doute
est permis maintenant en tout cas qu'ils
ont considéré qu'elle avait raté son
débat beaucoup plus que dans l'autre
sens je n'ai pas lu j'ai dû et des
milliers de commentaires depuis hier
soir mais je n'ai pas lu de militants
pro macron dire que il avait raté son
débat ça doit être
canam est rarissime alors que l'on va
voir y compris sur des formes telles que
discorde c'est à dire des forums bat à
mains des patriots au sila qui est sûr
discorde c'est à dire les militants les
vrais hardcore militants front national
qui vont militer sur les réseaux sociaux
de façon très organisée
y compris cela pour une partie en tout
cas on dit dès le débat qu'elle avait
été nul je cite que on se moquait d'elle
sur les réseaux sociaux on a appelé à
progresser l'époque de jean marie le pen
qui lui dans les débats auraient
probablement je cite à nouveau gagner ce
débat et aurait été meilleur voir que
monsieur philippot qui est censé
apparemment être un meilleur des
batteurs selon eux à nouveau que marine
le pen au casse-tête quand même ce
regret chez certains donc au final oui
probablement emmanuel macron qui gagne
ce débat tout à fait certain que
beaucoup de militants de marine le pen
garde la tête haute et disent que c'est
elle qui a gagné mais on sent quand même
que c'est un peu plus friable
alors on va continuer ce débat mais un
des angles d'attaqué choisi par la
candidate frontiste c'était l'héritage
des manuels macron l'héritage de
françois hollande
je vous propose de réécouter son
intervention monsieur le ministre de
l'économie doit jeudi ruche et le
conseil
auprès de monsieur hollande est votre
vision donc du marché du travail madame
latran et vous avez été conseiller
économique de françois hollande depuis
deux ans ministre mais si vous avez la
recette pour diminution mal en quoi est
ce que vous n'avez pas c'est un petit
canal pour le faire une somme candidat
presque facile en quoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas fait profiter
monsieur hollande de vos recettes
et parce que si vous n'avez pas de
recettes parce que vos résultats ont été
en l'occurrence extrêmement mauvais faut
le dire en matière de chômage
alors pourquoi vous vous présenter à la
présidence de la république c'est comme
la seule vraie question qu'on doit poser
là même le pen
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
votre stratégie mais c'est normal ça
fait des décennies que ça dure
votre stratégie c'est simplement de dire
beaucoup de mensonges et de dire tout ce
qui ne va pas dans le pays mais vous ne
proposez rien c'est celle créée puis on
a vu que cet argument de meritage a
difficilement pris hier comment vous
l'expliquez pas parce qu'en fait elle
l'a répété à l'envi et au bout d'un
moment on avait le sentiment que c'était
son seul argument d'ailleurs il lui
faisait remarquer mais développer votre
projet elles disent aimer vous êtes
socialiste vous êtes l'héritage de
hollande c'est un peu court alors ça
s'adressait probablement aux électeurs
de françois fillon pour montrer que
finalement il valait mieux pas qu'ils
portent leurs suffrages sur emmanuel
macron mais probablement que c'était un
peu court et que même ces derniers
peuvent au contraire avoir été un peu
déroutés par ses limites ou ses
imprécisions sur son programme
économique est finalement l'objectif qui
était de séduire cette partie de
l'électorat il n'est pas sûr qu'il ait
été remplies hier soir laurent bouvet
comme sarkozy l'avait fait en 2007
emmanuel macron a finalement réussi à
incarner et bien une certaine alternance
la rupture avec une période qu'ils
avaient en partie lui aussi écrite
oui à laquelle il a participé seul il a
été secrétaire général adjoint à
l'elysée auprès de françois hollande
dans la première partie du quinquennat
puis évidemment ministre de l'économie
dans la dans la seconde elle lui
rappelle mais il faut bien voir que ça
s'inscrit dans un contexte où les
socialistes même est très largement la
gauche ont expliqué pendant des mois de
campagne que macro n'était pas de gauche
que c'était pas
un socialiste qui l'étaient pas et c'est
alors comme il ya pas eu de débat sur le
bilan puisque personne dans cette
campagne a assumé évidemment le bilan de
françois hollande
pas plus macron que benoît hamon
évidemment donc du coup y'a pas il n'a
pas eu à à défendre le bilan à être en
avant il a dit moi je suis parti quand
je n'étais plus d'accord bon bacon qu'il
a il a rompu
comme tous les gens qui ont participé au
pro gouvernement et aussi on dit mais il
n'est pas de gauche il n'est pas
socialiste ce n'est pas un vrai temps il
n'a pas cette difficulté donc la marine
le pen est effectivement elle doit
revenir de très loin pour expliquer que
c'est l'héritier d'un don qu'on a on a
un contexte qui explique ça et puis ç'a
très bien été dit est là elle a répété
ad nauseam est là elle a été sur en fait
quand on regarde bien ce débat elle a
été sur un tout petit stock d'arguments
qui étaient des arguments extrêmement
agressif
elle devait conquérir des parts de
marché supplémentaires si on veut parler
de cette manière elle était sur un tout
petit stock d'arguments et derrière elle
avait pas beaucoup de biscuits on
s'aperçut que elle était peut-être un
petit peu juste aussi sur un certain
nombre de dossiers peut-être que florian
philippot dont on parlait tout à l'heure
a dit elle prépare ce débat depuis 20
ans et en même temps on voit qui a
compté pour elle c'est aussi de se faire
l'écho de la colère de l' angoisse bien
de ce qu'elle veut séduire mais ça n'a
pas suffi pour persuader les
téléspectateurs y a non mais c'est vrai
qu'on a vu que l'épisode de d'ouvrir
poule à amiens a quand même cristalliser
cette campagne d'entre deux tours on a
vu que c'était vraiment un marqueur hier
elle a l'art p t elle a eu ses seins
comme arguments et on voit quelques ça
pas forcément pris parce que manu
m'accrochant à fait cette campagne comme
les et laurent bouvet dès le début sur
le fait qu' il n'avait pas une n'est pas
comptable du bilan
en revanche elle dit elle a peut être
associée franc est mal macro à françois
hollande pour s'adresser aux électeurs
de françois fillon mais aussi aux
acteurs de jean luc mélenchon qui
reproche à ayman macron justement naître
comptable d'une certaine politique
sociale libérale d'avoir justement
soutenu la loi comme riz qu'elle appelle
l loi macron donc on voit qui a effectué
à l'essai de jouer sur les deux
électorats elle avait dossier d'une
vidéo il ya pas si longtemps où elles
s'adressaient directement à la france
est soumise
donc on voit qu'elle essaie de jouer sur
les deux électorats un petit peu friable
où les reports de voix ne sont pas
forcément certains prêts magne le
maquereau pour justement maximiser ses
chances d'être de gagner l'élection
dimanche prochain on va parler de la
caisse sans électeurs
la france est insuffisant
nicolas lebourg on voit que c'est aussi
une stratégie du mensonge qui est
clairement développé par marine le pen a
été mise à l'épreuve rudement hier aussi
face à toutes ces informations erronées
qui ont été démentie au fil de ce débat
par emmanuel macron alors le problème de
l'extrême-droite française c'est qu'elle
passe sa vie à citer un théoricien
communiste italien parce que ça fait
très jolie qui s'appelle antonio gramsci
en disant il faut faire la bataille
culturelle le prime ce qu'ils n'ont pas
lu gramsci qui l'ont pas compris il le
cite c'est différent l'idée de gramsci
c'est que certains il faut se battre sur
les idées sur les représentations mais
avec l'idée qu'il faut créer un bloc
d'alliance entre des groupes sociaux or
ça ils n'ont pas du tout saisi et le
problème c'est que les punchline
qu'utilise marine le pen on dit au front
national toujours on fait de la bataille
culturelle en faisant ça mais elles
construisent pas une alliance entre des
groupes sociaux il n'ya pas hier dans
les punchline qu'elle utilise dans les
faits que news qu'elle utilise quelque
chose qui construisent une offre
politique sérieusement ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que le prêt de marine le
pen a cru qu'elle avait eu la pierre
philosophale et florian philippot
qu'elle a crédibilisé le parti et
pouvoir en faire vraiment une offre
politique
or le problème c'est que l'offre
politique économique du front national
devient aujourd'hui un de ses pires
boulet quand on regarde marine le pen
aux élections présidentielles chez les
plus diplômés elle fait moins que
faisait son père faisait moins que vous
et jean marie le pen en 1988 chez les
plus diplômés qui ne trouvent pas ce
programme crédible
donc ça fait qu'elle alterne
effectivement des choses des
commentaires sur les banquiers des faits
que news etc etc en fait ça trouble un
petit peu ce message d'un front national
professionnaliser hélas well jérémie
manigne nicolas lebourg évoquer cette
question des faits que news on peut voir
une certaine similitude avec ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis avec
l'élection de donald trump il a aussi
dans le débat face à hillary clinton
beaucoup d'employés cette stratégie du
mensonge est là et bien ça avait
fonctionné aux états unis oui mais
peut-être qu'il était préparé cette fois
ci c'était plus un effet de surprise
donc c'était vraiment une campagne très
axé réseaux sociaux au sens où toutes
ces bonnes choses qu'on a évoqué on les
ai déjà vu mille fois sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis des semaines voire des
mois
je pense qu emmanuel macron et son
équipe ont eu largement le temps de se
préparer à ça et il est pas tombé dans
le piège de d'essayer de relever des
choses il a plutôt pris de la hauteur
d'ailleurs il ya un tweet qui a très
bien marché hier
qui dit grosso modo monsieur macron
c'est votre faute si d'un bol d'or est
mort à la fin d'harry potter vous étiez
ministre
à cette époque là est donc le prenait à
chaque fois je suis pas responsable de
tout j'étais ministre certes mais pas de
tous donc voilà une rentrée par un peu
l'ironie et l'humour pour contrer ses
punchlines là bon voilà du coup ça n'a
pas pris elle a agressé d'emblée mais ça
n'a pas pris
et comme on est resté sur la même
stratégie comme un boxeur qui essayent
de coincé dans les cordes son adversaire
sauf qu'il n'y allez pas dans les cordes
et justement je propose de réécouter une
des interventions de marine le pen
elle évoque et bien en gala merkel cette
fois de toute façon la france sera
dirigée par une femme ce sera au moins
où madame d'accord alors elle est là la
réalité était bien évidemment que
formulés l'arrivée heureusement notre
musée a eu des dirigeants visionnaires
vous laissez le faire mais madame le
maire est interrompue non mais non c'est
moi qui ai pas eu les dirigeants
visionnaires
le général de gaulle et le chancelier
adenauer ils ont su travailler ensemble
ils l'ont fait le avec il voulait plus
notre époque il noie sa fair play avant
ses punchlines n'ont pas fonctionné tout
au long de cette émission et christelle
avec rappelé oui effectivement il ya eu
un peut-être un problème de conviction
et surtout quand même les français
attendait un peu des détails sur les
propositions politiques c'est quand même
souvent l'objet de ces débats et là ça a
pu leur part est du coup assez pauvre
puisque finalement elle ne détaillait
pas ses propositions quand elle le
faisait elle était mise face à ses
contradictions
emmanuel macron avait un peu plus de
temps finalement utiliser davantage son
temps pour pour davantage exposé ses
propositions
après il faut voir aussi s'il arrivera
avoir convaincu sur ce sujet puisque ça
reste quand même sa faiblesse il ya une
grande partie de ses électeurs même
qu'ils votent pour lui
par défaut ou pour faire barrage au
front national tout l'enjeu pour lui
c'est d'arriver vraiment à convaincre
sur ses propositions pour générer
davantage un vote d'adhésion
ça sera effectivement un des enjeux et
notamment de son discours peut-être ce
soir à albi alors en bout
et comment ne pas être apparaître comme
un président par défaut
ça c'est l'enjeu en cas de victoire
d'emmanuel macron dimanche alors c'est
c'est effectivement très difficile il
est dans une situation où c'était c'est
très paradoxal ce qui ce qui est en
train d'arriver dans la vie politique
française avec la victoire d'emmanuel
macron qu'on attend pour dimanche
sauf accident majeur d'ici là bon on ne
sait jamais mais enfin là le retard de
marine le pen est tel que on ne risque
pas grand-chose à prédire cette ces
tissus le il et il a réussi un coup
extraordinaire dans la vie politique
française comme on n'en avait pas vu
depuis la 5ème république avec ce ce
jeune homme dans un pays où il faut
avoir été blanchi sous le harnais avoir
soit échoué plusieurs fois la
présidentielle soit comme nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande première
première candidature première victoire
mais après bon un parcours politique
très riche des films des deux côtés donc
là il arrive il n'a jamais été élu
il est il était inconnu il ya encore
trois ans ils déboulent il crée son
mouvement
ex nihilo alors qu' il fallait il faut
s'inscrire dans un mouvement il faut
avoir des militants il faut avoir en
partie des finances lui créé ça comme ça
etc
il élimine toutes les familles de la vie
politique française
une à une alors il bénéficie évidemment
toujours en politique c'est comme dans
la guerre il y a de la chance qui
intervient évidemment il a de la chance
mais il est il passe il passe entre les
gouttes son chemin il arrive il est là
mais évidemment c'est ça le paradoxe il
est certainement celui qui va arriver
comme président de la république le le
moins bien élu du point de vue non pas
de son score mais du point de vue de
l'adhésion à son projet ça va être un
président non pas on peut pas dire que
c'est un présent par défaut parce que la
vème république ne nous dit pas ce qu'il
y a dans chaque l'intention qu'il ya
dans chaque bulletin de vote le nom
d'emmanuel macro mais il y aura
évidemment un défaut parce que beaucoup
de gens ça a très bien été dit ne vont
pas voter pour son projet alors est ce
que c'est un avantage ou un inconvénient
comme on a vu que les deux précédents
présidents nicolas sarkozy et françois
hollande y avait une adhésion à la
rupture sarkozyste à la triangulation
sur le travail
on s'en souvient sur la nation etc il
avait piqué
si je me permets d électeurs à la fois
au front national est un peu à la gauche
donc il est il y arriver comme ça
françois hollande par rapport à sarkozy
est évidemment contre sarkozy donc sur
des projets forts sur une adhésion sur
quelque chose qui était voulue par la
droite par la gauche là on n'est pas
dans ce cas là est ce que ça ne lui
permettra pas de mieux réussir son
quinquennat que le deux présidents élus
avec un fort taux d'adhésion
ça ça va être l'expérience que nous
allons vivre en direct en france dans
les cinq années qui viennent leur un
problème de légitimité selon vous de
gibran on voit aujourd'hui est bien une
tribune de françois henri faim dans le
monde qui dit eh bien vous êtes déjà
allés c'est un président qui est déjà
allé il faut aussi mettre ça en
perspective avec la campagne pour les
chétive qui va commencer juste après
l'élection présidentielle juste après
dimanche et françois ruffin est candidat
on voit bien qu'à la flore marine le pen
et jean luc mélenchon commence déjà à
prévoir de s'attribuer le rôle du
premier opposant au futur président de
la république mais je pense qu'il ya
deux choses c'est que d'une part mais
même le cros a toujours été malin pour
désamorcer les pièges qu'on lui tendait
et à chaque fois qu'on l'attendait un
tournant de la vie politique la russie
justement à surprendre et a montré qu'il
était capable d'affronter une épreuve
donc comme laurent bouvet le disait
peut-être qu'il réussira encore une fois
à déjouer les pronostics
on parle aujourd'hui d'un rôle d'un
maquereau bashing alors même qu'il n'est
pas élu ou l'âge avec la rotonde par
exemple et d'autre part je pense que les
appels au vote utile qu'on a vue de part
et d'autre des de l'échiquier politique
n'aide pas non plus emmanuel macron à
fédérer à avoir importé l'adhésion le
mot utile en plus six fractures et des
votes inutile donc je pense que c'est
l'expression plus qu'on utilise dans les
médias mais n'entendent pas non plus
emmanuel macron a construit sa
légitimité en tant que président la
future prison la république éventuel
nicolas lebourg escalade jouer cette
carte de chef de l'opposition à venir
hier marine le pen selon vous on est
dans une situation délicate parce que
c'est une élection à 8 tours on à la
primaire de la droite on nous avait dit
ça sera le père de la république
résultats rappelez-vous les électeurs de
gauche discuté entre eux pour qui on
vote etc
c'était invraisemblable après on a eu la
primaire de la gauche c'était
particulier là on est on est et après
fictivement ne sais pas aujourd'hui on
en a pour la première fois deux
candidats qui sont là qui n'ont jamais
été députée eux de leur vie qu'ils n'ont
pas de groupe parlementaire on est dans
une situation totalement invraisemblable
l'élection sera fini qu'au mois de juin
à partir de là en plus une situation
difficile on dit hollande elle présente
plus impopulaire de la 5ème république
le président le plus impopulaire vème
république avant il s'appelle nicolas
cosy il ya un risque qui s'appelle
emmanuel macron prochain il ya vrai
délitement des institutions une vraie
difficulté est dans cette situation
totalement instable
on comprend qu'avec un second tour tant
il ya une responsabilité particulière
pour le prochain président de la
république qui devra faire baisser le
front national emmanuel macron et il est
bien la personnalité politique la plus à
même justement de faire front national
pour 105 ans je ne sais même par contre
ce dont je suis convaincu c'est pour
marine le pen pour ses électeurs pour
son parti il est extrêmement important
de dépasser le cap des 40 % de
constituer sert le double de ce qu'avait
fait le jean marie le pen en 2002 d'être
dans une position pour attaquer les
législatives en ayant le réel espoir
d'avoir un groupe parlementaire
elle ne peut pas arriver au début de
l'été en dix ans on avait deux députés
infineon 1 à 4 les gars hein parce
qu'avec la pression depuis cinq ans le
storytelling café marine le pen florian
philippot en disant nous allons prendre
le pouvoir nous le voulons nous l'aurons
il pourra pas y avoir une telle
déception pour son parti sans secousses
donc elle poussera au maximum pour être
là chef de l'opposition effectivement
elle parce que son destin personnel qui
se joue aussi bien sur jérémy magnon on
parlait de ce président qui risquent
peut-être d'être mal élu dimanche
sentiment de haine aussi à l'encontre
d'emmanuel macron est-ce que ça ressort
sur les réseaux clairement mais dès le
départ je serais tenté de dire quelle
était l'idée le départ en tant que
banquier et fils 2
et en fait on des regrets à reprocher à
la fois d'être très à droite est très
très à gauche
selon de quel point de vue on se
positionner donc quelque part n'y a pas
d' effet déceptif pour le coup puisqu'il
y avait dès le départ est à la limite
même ses militants je le disais sur un
autre plateau ya un petit moment
non non pas ne le pousse pas avec autant
d'enthousiasmé que un militant pro
frontiste pousserait pousserez marine le
pen y ait une sorte de côté raisonnable
beaucoup disent finalement heureusement
qu'il est là parce que s'il n'était pas
été là s'il n'est pas créé son parti
on aurait probablement marine le pen en
tant que présidente on va pas refaire
l'histoire mais c'est difficilement qui
aura pris la place qu'ils occupent la
place de l'homme neuf celui auquel on
est prêt à dire tiens bon tu n'en ont
pas encore essayé c'était le dernier
recours avant l'extrême droite donc
quelque part il ya un côté un peu
désabusé déjà c'est peut-être sa chance
parce que voilà il n'y aura pas d' effet
déceptif il peut faire que mieux vu que
tout le monde attend qu'il se plante par
manque d'expérience c'est quelque chose
qui se mesure également dans les
intentions de vote dans les sondages
justement ce sentiment est bien qu'il
pourrait être mal élu que cet ensemble
un président par défaut
marc effectivement comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure dans auprès de ses
électeurs il ya une partie qui nous
disent qu'ils votent par défaut ou pour
faire barrage au front national
mais c'est qu'ils m'ont même dans ses
traits d'image on a vu qu'ils aient son
image s'est dégradée par rapport à hier
même ne serait-ce que quelques mois
aujourd'hui paraît sympathique meilhan
les gens se questionnent sur les toffes
et ce qu'il a vraiment l'étoffé d'un
président il est quand même il n'a pas
une très bonne image sur le fait d'être
proche des gens proches de leurs
préoccupations
donc on voit qu'il ya quand même un
certain nombre effectivement de
difficulté est alors que françois
hollande déjà n'avait eu qu'un état de
grâce très limité quelques mois dès la
rentrée s'était terminée là
effectivement on peut se dire qu'il
n'est même pas élu qu'il a déjà beaucoup
de critiques
faudra voir effectivement si du coup ça
peut jouer plutôt en sa faveur parce
qu'il créera - 2 déception il aura quand
même à sa charge de refédérer les
français de recréer un élan parce que
quand au fil des enquêtes on s'aperçoit
qu'ils sont quand même extrêmement
pessimiste quand on leur demande leur
état d'esprit à l'égard de l'élection
sont des mots très forts qui ressorte le
pessimisme la colère même la révolte
c'est pas bon pour dans un pays il faut
quand même voilà qui kir feder et qui
recrée un petit peu de l'élan positif et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il essaie de
faire dans son discours mais pour
l'instant ils se heurtent quand même à
des difficultés à des français est très
très pessimiste très morose et justement
un christ elle rappelé dans cet
entre-deux-tours l'attitude des
électeurs de la france insoumise aura
été au centre de toutes les attentions
jean luc mélenchon nous dit qu'il votera
mais refuse de dire pour qui accusé
notamment de faire le jeu du front
national flora sauvages alors que les
soutiens de la france insoumise ont
choisi l'abstention et le vote blanc
dimanche face à marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon a refusé de donner une
consigne de vote
ce qui nous est demandé ce n'est pas un
vote anti fasciste ce n'est pas un vote
anti extrême droite ce que nous demande
sur macro il l'a dit mon un vote
d'adhésion
vous comprenez leur nom n'adhérons pas à
ce projet un positionnement qui
contraste avec celui adopté en 2002 à
l'époque jean luc mélenchon était
catégorique
désormais jean luc mélenchon et ses
soutiens ont pris leurs distances avec
le front républicain une position
ambiguë qui leur attire le feu des
critiques
on ne comprend pas quand on voit
l'attitude de marine le pen hier soir
y'a pas photo personne n'est pour le ni
ni personne ne m'ait singalo fâché par
le pot pour mes amis et je dis si
certains d'ailleurs m'avez fait
l'honneur ou avait fait l'honneur de
voter pour jean luc mélenchon et se
poser la question de voter pour le front
national je leur dis par votre
intermédiaire ne votez pas front
national en appelant à faire barrage
contre marine le pen sans appeler à
voter emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon
espère maintenir la dynamique pour la
bataille des législatives la france
insoumise compte présenter des candidats
dans plus de 500 circonscription et les
relations avec le parti communiste sont
tendues dans un communiqué le mouvement
de jean luc mélenchon exige l'arrêt
immédiat de l'utilisation de la photo du
leader de la france a soumise par le pc
laurent bouvet on
on voit bien la difficulté pour les
électeurs pour jean luc mélenchon qui
veut capitaliser sur son score quasiment
20% au premier tour ils refusent de
soutenir ouvertement emmanuel macron ça
pourrait il a fait venir pour les
législatives pourtant c'est une
stratégie risquée au signal voix qui
l'avait accusé de faire le jeu il est
dans une position très difficile à être
bon d'abord il ya une grande déception
parce que les bons ça c'est quand même
joué à pas grand chose
tout ça avec françois fillon puis avec
marine le pen on est dans des dents des
écarts très faibles donc il y avait
vraiment une il ya eu une telle
dynamique de la campagne de mélenchon 1
dans les quinze derniers jours qu'il
pensait vraiment pouvoir être au second
tour il a pris une position que
j'appellerais de précaution de comme un
principe de précaution pour garder le
plus unis possible cette france
insoumise qui n'est pas un parti un qui
est un mouvement
on a des mouvements c'est très
intéressant alors on va pas faire de
mise sur l'essieu mais du point de vue
de l'évolution des partis politiques de
la manière dont s'organise la vie poli
donc c'est un mouvement dans lequel il y
à un parti très structurelles parti
communiste qui a immédiatement pris une
position en faveur du vote macron dès le
soir du premier tour on s'en souvient ça
c'est les relations mélenchon parti
communiste sont très difficiles on se
rappelle qu'il a été candidat sans
demander son avis au parti communiste
il a pris de vitesse le parti communiste
pour ne pas avoir à subir ce qu'ils
avaient subi et en 2012 donc il a un
parti et puis la d des adhérents directs
on aurait dit une autre époque
il a des petits des petits groupuscules
il a des gens qui sont très très à
gauche qui ne qui ne veulent pas du
pouvoir il
il a beaucoup de choses la france
insoumis et le référendum entre
guillemets qui a eu lieu la votation
citoyenne pour décider quelle
installation la consultation
a bien montré qu'il y avait une
diversité très grande et donc lui
son but c'est d'essayer de préserver au
maximum les options alors évidemment les
législatives on est très difficile parce
que avec une telle diversité
on va avoir certainement d'aider des
effets de candidature on voit déjà que
le parti communiste prépare ses
législatives qui qui risque d'être une
deuxième déception donc là je reviens
sur mon propos du début pour tous ces
militants notamment des jeunes qu'il a
su séduire c'est la première fois qu'à
nouveau on l'a vu un petit peu en marche
il ya aussi aussi des jeunes c'est pas
les mêmes évidemment il ya un front
national bien sûr traditionnellement ces
trois types de jeunes très différents
mais il a su séduire des jeunes ils
assurent ramener les catégories
populaires qui ne votent plus à gauche
depuis un moment donc il simplement y
avoir une deuxième déception parce que
ben ça va être très très difficile pour
les candidats étiquette france insoumise
d'être élu député etc
donc on va voir l'art à quelque chose
qui pourrait s'effriter dans le temps
parce que la personnalité de jean-luc
mélenchon dans une présidentielle a été
le ciment ainsi montré puis centre avec
grâce à son talent grâce à sa qualité de
candidat qui ne sera pas présent dans
toutes les circonscriptions
donc là ça va être je pense très
difficile pour la france un soumise dans
les semaines qui viennent nicolas v
voici encore des électeurs de la france
un sommet ce qui pourrait se diriger
vers marine le pen au second tour
alors c'est très intéressant parce que
sont les données de l'ifop j'ai pas vu
cette votre institut vous me pardonnez
ce de l'ifop de cheveux souviennent le
du lendemain du premier tour à hier on
est passé de 20 points d'intention à 13
points une baisse de 7 points
macron restant stable à peu près autour
de 50 ses 7 points partant vers
l'abstention et vera le vote blanc est
alors choses encore plus passionnante
quand on regarde les catégories d'âge ce
sont les gens qui vont voter blanc ou
qu'ils s'abstiennent ceux qui refusent
donc de choisir entre monsieur macro et
madame le pen
ce sont des gens qui était électeur en
2002 ce sont des gens qui ont fait le
front républicain en 2002 sans doute
qu'ils ont pu voter pour jacques chirac
et qui ont peut-être pu se dire ensuite
mon dieu tout ça pour ça est ce que
c'était vraiment utiles etc
il ya des vraies questions qui se posent
là d'un comportement de jean luc
mélenchon
leur ton voit bien ce alors que le plus
les gens qui ont plus une culture de
gauche classique même temps toute sa
campagne a été basée sur le principe de
rompre avec la culture de gauche
classique on range l'international
oranje le drapeau rouge en renta certain
nombre d'élus référents et on essaie de
construire quelque chose d'autre donc
c'est assez intéressant dans tous les
cas voilà le vote des mélenchonistes
tout madame le pen sont les données de
l'ifop il avait 7 7 points mettant fin
des données assez similaire on a
effectivement un peu moins de la moitié
des électeurs de jean luc mélenchon qui
se reportent quand même sur emmanuel
macron qui se distingue en cela donc
très clairement des personnes qui ont
voté dans le cadre de la consultation
des insoumis on a un gros tiers un peu
plus qui va vers l'abstention et nous on
avait encore 18% avant donc le c était
une mesure qui datent de d'avant le
d'emma qui se portaient sur sur marine
le pen elle leur a tendu la main barrée
ne pas nier hier nous avons en parlant
de la loi travail on écoute essayer de
faire oublier que vous allez participer
à un gouvernement qui a mis en oeuvre la
loi elle comme rick a été une loi encore
une fois de précarisation du travail qui
n'a pas créé un emploi qui a créé un
chômage qui est encore plus important
depuis que vous êtes partis du
gouvernement que quand vous y est entré
mais ça je vois que vous refusé d'en
assumer la responsabilité de thomas j'ai
implicitement mais je note que vous
refusez encore une fois cette
responsabilité donc les mesures que vous
préconisez aujourd'hui c'est bon les a
vus si vous nous dit on va faire ça
empire
et bien moi je dis qu'il faut évidemment
radicalement tourné le dos à cette
politique là et il faut enfin fait une
politique de protection
encore une fois des emplois et de
développement des tpe pme parce que ce
sont elles qui créent l'emploi dans
notre pays
les tpe pme qu'est ce qu'elle demande
vous avez été voir les chefs
d'entreprise ils veulent quoi plus de
visibilité
ils veulent pouvoir qu'ils soient tpe
pme entreprises de taille intermédiaire
c'est pas du tout les grands groupes qui
le demandent les grands groupes qui
gèrent très bien la complexité fille
s'en fiche complètement
mais toutes ces entreprises de
l'entreprise d'un salarié jusqu'à 500
elles veulent quoi elles veulent plus
d'adaptation à leur réalité économique
une entreprise qui est dans le btp qui a
deux salariés elle n'a pas le même
quotidien qu'une startups du numérique
aucune entreprise qui a 500 salariés
dans l'automobile ce n'est pas la même
réalité et donc il faut leur laisser la
possibilité
de négocier pour certaines un accord
majoritaire d'entreprise les grands
groupes seul le peuvent aujourd'hui dans
certaines circonstances et ont sauvé des
emplois via jebrane on voit clairement
dans la description de marine le pen
qu'elle présente emmanuel macron comme
le candidat de la casse sociale de la
brutalité sociale de la précarisation là
aussi c'est un message aux électeurs de
la france insoumise c'est l'envol oui
complètement elle sait très bien que
c'est une des choses qu'on reproche
justement à emmanuel macron d'être se
tenant de cette politique françois
hollande a mené dans les deux dernières
années de son quinquennat
plutôt sociale libérale et jean luc
mélenchon d'ailleurs on a vu un extrait
je sais plus où jean luc mélenchon ne
disait que pour que les insoumis
puissent voter pour les mâles macron il
fallait qu'ils reviennent sur sa
proposition d'une loi travail bis ce que
justement emmanuel macron à chaque fois
on refuse de faire refusant de rentrer
dans le jeu du système de négociation
avec des appareils politiques sur des
accords de gouvernement il marine le pen
et c'est justement aussi de l'entraîner
là dedans en essayant de devoir 6-2 le
maître de le pousser dans ses
retranchements et voir s'il peut reculer
sur ses propositions là et on voit
quelques elle qu'il refuse de jeu de
jouer à ce jeu moi juste de mer
provocatrice par baur reports de voix
que les que les insoumis pourrait
pourrait apporter à marine le pen je
suis un peu étonné qu'on n'est pas une
chose justement dans la consultation
entre les différents réjouis exactement
le pen était pas dans les trois choix
qui était proposé aux insoumis la
consultation
j'irai même année sur cette question ces
réservoirs de voix constitua les
électeurs de la france et insoumise
envoyer aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
ce maître est bien en place une sorte de
hashtag ni le pen mini macron vous
relayer par les étudiants les lycéens
qui ont été effectivement celui dans
lequel peu partout ces venues d'un peu
partout rimac rond alors nous on n'a pas
de chiffres à donner par contre on
allait les verbatim les commentaires qui
viennent expliquer pourquoi je passe de
linge basque de l'un à l'autre et c'est
vrai que cette frange là de deux
militants qui dit déçu du vin plutôt
qu'ils venaient mélange pions et qu'ils
étaient prêts à voter front national
d'ailleurs qui au départ était probable
un front national qui ont finalement
changé d'avis pour voter au premier tour
mêlant chant puis qui reviennent à leurs
premières amours
il explique pourquoi le doute commence à
s'insinuer et alors ça fait que moins de
24 heures que le débat et est passé mais
on est passé d'un débat sur les valeurs
de ni nationalisme ni libéralise
un débat sur la compétence et c'est pas
pareil je pense que ça changera et ça
fera changer les idées d'un certain
nombre de gens qui étaient pro front
national sans adhérer sur les valeurs
parce que autant les valeurs et les
mettez dos à dos autant la compétence
est plus difficile de soutenir qu'on va
aller voter pour quelqu'un qui
visiblement selon beaucoup de gens n'est
pas apparu comme compétente maîtrisant
ces dossiers on rappelle la somme de
dossiers on rappelle et les vins erreur
en une heure don a été fait tout ça ils
l'entendent et ça les rend plus
difficiles donc à chaque fois c'est je
voterai avec le bout des doigts
peut-être les pinceaux des gants comme
disait mélenchon en 2002 mais il
explique que voilà c'est à cause de ça
notamment de ce seul manque de
compétences perçu désormais et du fait
qu'on ne parle plus que de ça depuis
moins de 24 heures qu'il risque
finalement de soit s'abstenir soit
éventuellement de voter macron en tout
cas de retirer leur vote à marine le pen
françois hollande a d'ailleurs déclaré
un que l'ignorance de marine le pen sur
l'euro ne lui permet pas d'être
présidente de la république le débat a
révélé le projet non seulement
incohérent mais dangereux de marine le
pen vous avez pu aussi mesurer peut-être
dans les intentions de vote le caractère
président un siècle de chaque candidat à
l'issue de ce débat alors on l'a pas
fait à l'issue du débat on l'avait fait
avant effectivement on a globalement des
personnalités politiques qui ont des
mauvaise image auprès des français
emmanuel macron marine le pen n'échappe
pas forcément à cette généralisation
effectivement on n'avait qu'une minorité
de français qui considérait que emmanuel
macron avait l'étoffé d'un président
c'était quand même davantage que la
proportion de personnes qui pensaient la
même chose pour marine le pen
donc sur ce point il avait quand même
déjà un avantage à voir si celui ci va
se renforcer
à l'issue de ce débat en revanche il
avait quand même un certain déficit sur
la notion de proximité de comprendre les
préoccupations des français où la marine
le pen même si elles n'étaient pas
majoritaires avec des scores meilleur qu
emmanuel macron donc on voit que lui
pour lui il ya une question de stature
qui va devoir développer mais il a un
peu plus d'atouts pour le moment sur ce
sujet c'est surtout en terme de
proximité avec notamment les classes
plus populaires qui va devoir voilà
travailler parce que pour l'instant il a
clairement déficit d'image dans ce
domaine là on va faire un autre match
et hop une petite parenthèse rapide mais
après le soutien comme très appuyé de
barack obama qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue qui est un soutien très avec
beaucoup de connivence les doigts
longtemps dit j'ai appelé monsieur macro
ont fini par dire en marche en france et
voilà c'est un appui fort donc on verra
si ça rehausse sa stature autant le
soutien d'angela merkel pouvait faire le
jouer le jeu pardon de de marine le pen
mais parce que ça montre et la
connivence franco-allemande qu'elle
dénonce autant celui de barack obama est
un poids lourd qui donne un costume un
peu plus épais à emmanuel macron dans sa
peau ce possible stature présidentielle
laurent bouvet ont parlé de ce sentiment
et bien d'une candidate à l'ecoute qui
comprend les français c'est n'a
d'ailleurs pas un hasard si elle a
choisi de terminer bien ses meetings par
la somme c'est une campagne sur la
france des oubliés sur cette stratégie
du front national elle sait qu'elle aura
quand même porté ses fruits puisque
marine le pen est quand même au second
tour d'une élection présidentielle bédié
vous avez que je pense que la somme
supérieure
il ya quelque chose qui est amusant sur
la somme qu'on peut rappeler deux
secondes en 2002 je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez de saad et signe avant
coureur que lionel jospin va être
éliminé après coup évidemment quand on
regarde les choses
après coup c'est la sphère des
inondations de la somme avec une folle
rumeur qui fait que monsieur jospin est
pris à partie par des gens m'ont dit
s'il ya eu des inondations
c'est parce qu'en fait c'est des eaux
que vous avez enlevé parie que vous avez
envoyé vers la somme de manière à ce que
les parisiens voilà reste au sec et ça
veut dire beaucoup de choses cette
manière d'ennuyer aux territoires hors
paris pour laisser paris au sec et à
dire beaucoup de choses sur les tensions
qui a dans ce pays qui nous expliquait
le 21 avril en 2002 qui nous explique
france madame le pénal et lui pardon lui
était allé voir les inonder de la sorte
doublée d'un père et c'est avec ses
bottes sur les planches et il ya vu une
dame une pauvre dame je me rappelle de
cette image devant sa maison inondée qui
avait de l'eau jusque là elle avait des
cuissardes et elle était comme ça ils
étaient en surplomb et puis la dame lui
dise exactement ça vous nous avez noyer
pour sauver pas risqué
d'huile hydraulique n'est pas possible
mais peu importe c'était et lionel
jospin en bon rationaliste lui disais
mais madame ce que vous dites c'est
impossible ne dit pas de bêtise
la dame était avec de l'eau jusque là
lui premier ministre au sec d'en haut
lui disais mais madame voilà donc là il
y avait c'était c'est c'était une des
images de lionel jospin absolument
terrible dans cette campagne raté de
2002 mais alors quand la valeur de ce
qu'il faut bien voir le ce qu'essaye de
jouer marine le pen c'est un jeu qui
date depuis le début des années 90
depuis après la chute de mur du berlin
ou au front national il ya cette idée de
on va faire exploser le clivage droite
gauche en imposant un clivage les
patriots contre les mondialistes
alors vous comprenez bien l'intérêt si
on dit qu'il ya plus de clivage droite
gauche comme partie de la presse le fait
depuis 15 jours en dix ans à la france
du non la france du oui en reprenant les
éléments de langage de marine le pen
ça veut dire qu'elle pût d'extrême
droite et c'est très important pour le
front national d'en finir avec cette
étiquette d'extrême droite c'est pour ça
qu'ils appuient autant le rêve du front
national c'est de réussir
effectivement à fédérer la france du non
tant les nationalistes que les anti
libéraux de gauche etc
en pouvant transformer ce qui est une
sociologie électorale effectivement on a
vu que sur le vote macron le pen des
différents selon l'habitat selon le
diplôme etc
mais transformer ce qu une sociologie
une géographie en descendant c'est pas
la sociologie ce pas la géographie
l'idéologie et cette idéologie là c'est
celle qui peut nous permet d'aller au
pouvoir non c'est peut-être une
stratégie géniale
le seul problème c'est qu'elles datent
d'il ya trente ans donc manifestement
elle est pas facile à appliquer pourtant
si on suit votre théorie mais emmanuel
macron était le candidat idéal a frappé
pour marine le pen
le mondialiste façon oui c'est vrai que
la potion de macron qui se dit aussi en
dix thèmes et qui essaie d'installer un
autre clivage entre progressistes et
conservateurs pour cent je pense qu'une
françois fillon serait plutôt son
adversaire saga peu sur des massacres
ont été une cible un peu facile pour
marine le pen
mais je pense que là aussi beaucoup
péché par son impréparation par sa non
maîtrisée dossier par son attitude aussi
très agressive qui a justement cas c'est
un petit peu 7,7 la pertinence de son
attaque par baur mondialistes je pense
que le font effectivement elle aurait
plié jouer sur ce terrain là mais la
forme et on voit qu'elle a fait une très
mauvaise campagne de premier tour et un
frémissement entre les deux tours avec
whirpool etc
mais elle a fait
est-ce campagne présidentielle malgré
toute attente effectivement je pense que
la forme a complètement miné le fond et
sur cette campagne d'entre deux tours
puisque emmanuel macron avait une
campagne un début raté un ça commence
dans la séquence rotonde
on voit après bien des atermoiements au
niveau de son entourage
et puis elle a démarré et en fait marine
le pen lui a fourni le l'étincelle du
démarrage parce que ce qui était prévu
au warm pool de sa discussion avec
l'intersyndicale le fait qu'elles
qu'elles aillent de manière totalement
impromptue faire un happening sur le
parking de whirlpool en faisant des
selphy et cetera fait que manuel macron
sort de sa réunion avec l'intersyndicale
perdant de la séquence parce que lui
était enfermé marine le pen lui dit oui
vas manger comme ça dans son coin il
était à la rotonde ans est épaté riz et
là il va au contact
il se fait huer il rentre dans
l'entreprise et là il reste 10 buts et
quand ils repartent pas si vous avez
remarqué
personne ne lui ses délires qui est il
dit quelque chose ça ramène aussi à la
campagne de 2002 lionel jospin
l'état ne peut pas tout grandes phrases
terribles de lionel jospin simplement
lionel jospin en 2002 quand il dit
l'état ne peut pas tout ça s'arrête là
et tout le monde se dit mais c'est quoi
la gauche mais qu'est ce qu'il est il ne
les explique pas ce que fait manuel
macro ouvrier doit le pool il leur dit
l'état ne peut pas tout je ne pourrais
pas je ne peux pas vous promettre des
choses que je ne pourrais pas tenir il
fait aussi du contre sarkozy à hayange
et du con tre hollande sur la
camionnette à florange pour ne pas avoir
dans un encan walpole va fermer les
mêmes problèmes
mais il explique pourquoi l'état ne peut
pas tout il est le pédagogue il est
celui qui vient expliquer face à des
gens qui n'en peuvent plus qui vont
perdre leur boulot
voilà ce qu'on peut faire mais moi je ne
peux pas vous promettre que je ne
pourrais pas faire et ça là dessus ils
gagnent en compétences ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure tout le monde se dit bon
on aime peut-être pas c'est peut-être
pas on va voter quand même le pen parce
que bon tout ça mais enfin quand même le
type vient là est dit voilà voilà ce que
je le pédagogue face à l'as démagogues
ça saigne atteint
l'opposition très clivée quelque chose
qui ressort aussi dans les sondages dans
les sondages c'est plus difficile à
mesurer effectivement mais effectivement
on a remarqué que quel manuel macron est
insistez beaucoup sur sur ces
éléments-là refusait de faire des
promesses qui après la et langages et
surtout si voilà la réalité faisait
qu'il ne pourrait pas les tenir
ça c'est un discours qui peut
effectivement porter qui est quand même
à double tranchant parce que pour
l'instant voilà et forcément les gens
ont aussi envie d'être séduit et c'est
moins facile à entendre ces trois
histoires 60%
il serait y serez à 52 keita puis et
puis le pendant négatif c'est que voilà
il manque aussi une mesure forte qu'on
retient de manière très comme l'avait
été la et les heures supplémentaires en
2007 et du coude à force d'avoir un
discours très rationnel bah du coup
forcément il n'a pas cette mesure fait
baver voilà ça marche pas mais il a plus
de mal mais ses militants le dise
fofolle et surtout pas faire d'erreur va
essayer de chercher quelque chose qui
donnerait le bâton pour se faire battre
au cas où la mesure soit exactement pour
ça que parce qu'on disait dans l'eure
sur son quinquennat quelqu'un qui arrive
qui est kim qui ne fait pas rêver qui
n'est pas dans la rupture qui n'est pas
dans l'espoir peut-être que finalement
ça va être positif pour lui parce que le
jour où ça va mal ou alors le pool ferme
personne va lui reprocher d'avoir menti
d'avoir dit n'importe quoi donc il va
pouvoir gérer les choses en apparaissant
comme le type qui le petit peu président
pardon c'est viviane mais à ce moment là
qu'ils qui réussit quand même à à faire
changer les choses qui réussit à trouver
des solutions
hélas apparaître comme quelqu'un
finalement qui est beaucoup plus
efficace que quelqu'un qui aurait promis
et ne tient pas j'arrive mélanie on voit
aussi que en cette fin de campagne
elle va se jouer sur le terrain
judiciaire avec cette annonce faite hier
par marine le pen de comptes off shore
une information très vite relayé sur les
rangs
sociaux quel rôle ont ils eu dans sept
camps cette jument qu'alors les réseaux
sociaux vont j'y revenais mais ce point
s'il assure la fête new sur les comptes
offshore s'étaient vus comme une
catastrophe c'est une fête nous les
sources viennent de deux sources ont
relativement nauséabonde ça passe par
les etats-unis la russie ça a pas l'air
crédible du taux de change déjà été
probablement mais en tout cas voilà ça
tombe un peu comme un cheveu sur la
soupe
ça semble être la dernière chance et
j'ai l'impression que même dans son camp
on n'y croit pas donc tout cas les
militants que s'expriment 10 secondes
cela on va essayer de le relayer mais on
sent pas l'enthousiasmé on pourrait les
pousser
l'information sur les réseaux sociaux
essayer de faire changer obtient donc
voila c'était une cartouche car tous
mouillés dans les réseaux sociaux ça a
joué je pense que ça a joué parce que on
l'a vu hélas le débat était très
agressif mais parce que toute la
campagne était agressive et notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux on s'est battus
que à coup de punch line je pense que la
force de front national sur les réseaux
sociaux sikhs 1 ils sont très organisés
et 2 les 140 caractères de twitter c'est
parfait quand on est un peu démagogues
parce que c'est facile de dire il suffit
de sortir de l'euro aura eu nos
problèmes paf soutien en 140 caractères
pour contredire cet argument là il en
faut beaucoup plus que 140 c'est plus
compliqué et ça demande un peu de
pédagogie mais là pour la première fois
il avait marine le pen n'avait pas face
à elle
à un journaliste qui n'est pas censé
faire le débat est donc qui lui sert la
question est qui prend la réponse elle
avait un contradicteur qui a eu le temps
en une heure et quelques de démonter
chaque argument et on a vu que ça
marchait
donc c'était une erreur ne pas essayer
de rentrer dans le plus dans son débat
et désire reprendre à nouveau les mêmes
punchline qu'on avait tous déjà vu
diageo brade sur ce rôle des réseaux
sociaux notamment et bien d'extrême
droite très puissant sur internet sur
twitter sur facebook est ce qu'ils ont
eu un rôle particulier dans cette
campagne
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont eu un rôle
de défouloir parce que je pense que
beaucoup de gens et des frustrés de la
qualité du débat et puis du fait qu'ils
avaient quelques fruits ni sur le
plateau je pense qu'avec déjà eu un rôle
de défouloir pour tous les gens qui
s'intéressent à la politique et qui ont
été très déçus du débat dans cette
campagne et la préfecture à cette
campagne ça a permis justement de
véhicules est à la fois défectueuses
mais aussi des vrais arguments avec de
vraies stratégies de riposte côté mise
en place par les différents mouvements
au parti donc je pense que les réseaux
sociaux déjà depuis 2008 aux états unis
barack obama 2012
la stratégie très proactif de françois
hollande sur les réseaux sociaux
cette année je pense qu'on a vu toute
l'ampleur on se rappelle aussi il sait
pas vraiment sociale mais la chaîne
youtube de jean luc mélenchon qui a été
après répliqué par florian philippot
avec beaucoup moins de succès mais en
tout cas ça a permis justement de
s'affranchir des médias si on n'était
pas invitée sur les plateaux télé ça me
permettait justement de créer un canal
direct entre les militants les
sympathisants et les hommes politiques
juste part pour l'afrique nous où on se
rappelle aussi que cette fête nous avait
déjà circulé une semaine avant le
premier tour il y avait déjà été
démenties ont dit que le canard allait
sortir le mercredi 11 mai et/ou nicolas
lebourg seul aspect air et réseaux
sociaux notamment
est ce qu'on appelle parfois la
fachosphère oui mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en même temps la
chaîne jean luc mélenchon a très bien
fonctionné en même temps six meetings
lala mieux les meetings on pourrait dire
c'est la politique comme il ya des
décennies ont été absolument
extraordinaire en influence et en force
à renouveler les choses
ça a été une campagne assez vivante
alors après c'est vrai que l'effet que
nous c'est devenu vraiment quelque chose
de permanent
j'ai vu l'autre jour l'un des
journalistes des décodeurs et le conseil
a voté les spectateurs d'utiliser les
décodeurs du monde pour détecter les
faits que nous qui a montré une la fecq
news c'était emmanuel macron a choisi
manuel valls comme premier ministre
évidemment l'idée vous démobilisez les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon au
maximum en agitant pour le drapeau
absolue non ça nourrit effectivement le
débat et on voit bien qu au delà l'idée
au départ de ce qu'on appelle je joue
souvent la fachosphère qui préférerait
évidemment elle même sapée la
réinfosphère as assez bonne guerre
l'idée c'est de remplacer les médias
l'idée c'est de détruire la réputation
des médias de manière systématique ce
n'est pas d'être un complément
d'information c'est de les remplacer
c'est de les tuer et ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui l'a en
termes de bataille culturelle est
quelque chose de bien penser de biens
construits il ya en france à des gens
comme jean yves le gallou qu'un
intellectuel d'extrême droite qui a
engagé en politique de très longtemps
qui est un homme qui a des idées assez
radicale mais quitte un homme qui a un
certain niveau intellectuel un qui a une
capacité à penser des stratégies et lui
ça fait plus de dix ans qu'il est sur
cette idée là sur la construction de ce
qu'il appelle donc lui la réinfosphère
et je crois que ça cache un vrai fait
aujourd'hui on est devant un public
annie ils ont gagné sa bataille
culturelle r2p zone oui c'est vrai parce
qu'il suffit de regarder tous les
articles de la presse notamment en ligne
qui disent que c'est emmanuel macron qui
a gagné cette élection
vous allez voir que systématiquement le
média va se faire attaquer encore un
journaliste pro mac ont encore un média
pro mâcon c'est normal que vous pensiez
que alors même donc les médias celui des
quatre ont qui sont les amis de macron
qui sont qui tiennent les groupes de
presse ont il a été cité par marine le
pen hier soir évidemment dry bfm là
c'est donc on voit bien que qui a repris
les mots des ratés derrière l'idée de du
capitalisme des banquiers des temps
c'est tout tout se boucle 1 c'est très
bien fait effectivement du point de vue
de la guérilla du match et oui il joue
aussi sur la défiance grandissante des
français qu'on mesure la dans les
enquêtes à l'égard des médias
traditionnels des journalistes et du
coup ils s'appuient sur voilà une
défiance aussi forte dans l'opinion sur
ce sujet alors on a parlé en du
casse-tête des mélenchonistes que les
conséquences sont aussi tangible pour le
party les républicains car vous allez le
voir les stratégies divergent sur
l'attitude à adopter pour le second tour
soutenir ou pas emmanuel macron le débat
fragilise une droite déjà affaibli par
la défaite de françois fillon
on y associe au soir de sa défaite sans
hésiter françois fillon appelle à voter
pour emmanuel macron une résolution qui
tranche avec les atermoiements qui ont
agité son parti dans les jours suivants
face au front national
l'abstention ne peut être un choix
nous appelons à voter contre marine le
pen
lr n'appellent pas formellement à voter
emmanuel macron pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
une posture qui fuit sur l'unité de la
famille des personnalités comme bruno le
maire alain juppé xavier bertrand
christian estrosi françois baroin et
même nicolas sarkozy annonce qu'ils
voteront mâcon sans état d'âme
ils ne sont pas les seuls votre hamac
rond par défaut total en parler y a pas
de campagne pour macro n'y a pas de
soutien maintenant il n'y a pas
d'alliance avec mâcon ils sont combien
candidat est un acte 2 si vous dites
faire battre le front national ça
revienne quand même bien à dire
que c'est ma grande désolé je vous dise
pour une frange du parti
cette stratégie est suicidaire en vue
des législatives au nom de la cohérence
laurent wauquiez eric ciotti georges
fenech
nadine morano et pierre lellouche refuse
de demander aux électeurs de droite de
voter macro le combat c'est macron c'est
pas aujourd'hui qu'il va falloir tracté
pour mac ont jusqu'au 7 mai c'est pas
possible je peux pas j'ai des désaccords
absolument fondamentaux avec lui sur un
certain nombre de sujets majeurs
pierre lellouche a depuis claqué la
porte de son parti ait quitté la vie
politique mais dans l'hypothèse d'une
victoire d' emmanuel macron une partie
des républicains ne ferme aucune porte
françois baroin se prépare à matignon en
cas de cohabitation
bruno le maire se dit prêt à travailler
avec lui et les juppéiste n'insultons
pas l'avenir ou ne pourront pas ignorer
le résultat de la présidentielle et nous
opposer surtout ce serait destructeur au
moment où la france a besoin de réformes
le ton du débat d'entre deux tours à
conforter les partisans du vote macron à
droite sur twitter gérald darmanin réagi
comment peut-on encore proposé le vote
blanc ou l'abstention
après avoir vu cela et alain juppé lance
un dernier appel
maintenant il va falloir voter je le
répète avec solennité s'abstenir ou
voter blanc c'est faire le jeu du fn un
message adressé à tous les électeurs et
surtout à ses partenaires et l'eire qui
refusent toujours d'assumer un vote pour
le candidat face à marine le pen elle a
rappelé que disent les reports de voix
les intentions de vote chez les
électeurs fillonniste vont-ils se
prononcer pour une abstention et un vote
blanc ou pour un vote macron à lors de
notre dernier à mesure on a presque la
moitié des électeurs de françois fillon
46 % qui nous disent qu'ils vont voter
emmanuel macron qui se reportent
largement fin majoritairement sur lui on
a quand même 31% donc presque un tiers
qui disent au contraire qu'ils vont
voter pour marine le pen donc ce qui
traduit quand même les divisions au sein
de cet électorat et l'attirance pour une
partie de ses électeurs
pour marine le pen et puis on a 23 %
donc un car qui va vers le vote blanc ou
vert l'abstention et qui refuse de
choisir
donc même si on a une petite majorité
vers emmanuel macron on voit bien quand
même les divisions qui s'exprime aussi
bien chez les électeurs de françois
fillon ont parlé des difficultés de jean
luc mélenchon se sont quasiment les
mêmes qui frappe le parti
public à laurent bouvet mais on voit que
cette élection a bouleversé a fait
turbuler c'était l'expression utilisée
par jean pierre chevènement en 2002 le
système politique français
tous les partis sont touchés on parlait
tout à l'heure de la difficulté que
risquent d'avoir marine le pen si le
score n'est pas celui espéré
bon le parti socialiste a été est
quasiment éliminée au premier tour on
voit que on a parlé de mélenchon on voit
les républicains la question chez les
républicains va être c'est je dirais
c'est un peu ridicule de dire ça mais
c'est presque encore plus grave que
pourquoi pierre luc mélenchon à la
française ou pourquoi les républicains
parce qu'ils avaient élection gagnée
rappelons-nous six mois en arrière bon
l'élection imperdable
ils perdent l'élection imperdable avec
bon candidat fillon tout le monde sait
ce qui lui est arrivé pourquoi est un
ils ont gagné pendant cinq ans pendant
tout le quinquennat toutes les élections
intermédiaires
vous avez ils ont remplacé la france qui
était devenu pendant dix ans une france
plus tôt avec des élus de gauche
socialistes et majorité et c'est partout
dans les villes dans les régions etc
et normalement les législatives qui
arrivent sont un couronnement car une
circonscription législative qu'est ce
que c'est ce sont des villes ce sont des
cantons ça c'est dans une région est
évidemment quand vous avez des élus
quand vous avez un maillage quand vous
avez des gens pour faire campagne et
c'est un parti avec beaucoup d'élus de
l'argent qui va avec et c'est à vous
avez de bonnes chances d'avoir de gagner
les élections législatives là ils sont
dans une grande difficulté le
l'offensive macron les divise
profondément certains pensent ça n'a pas
été cité dans votre sujet mais
éventuellement à se déclarer dès après
la présidentielle pour rejoindre ce qui
serait peut-être la majorité
présidentielle autour des malbars entre
coalition alors qu'il devait être le
parti de l'alternance
après françois hollande quelques tous
convergé vers cela dont ils sont dans
une dans un moment historique où on peut
avoir comme il ya une division de la
gauche qui risque d'avoir une division
du parti socialiste il pourrait y avoir
une vision de la droite et du parti qui
a été créée depuis le début des années
2000 depuis l'ump pour réunir l'ensemble
des familles de droite
nicolas lebourg on n'a pas parlé non
plus du ralliement de nicolas dupont
aignan à marine le pen ce serait son
premier ministre en cas d'élections
c'est ce qu'elle a annoncé
est-ce que ça participe aussi ce
ralliement peut-être la banalisation la
dédiabolisation si elles existent du
front national le front national adore
ça ils appellent toujours ça des prises
de guerre alors c'est la même expression
que soit franck de la personne nicolas
dupont aignan là désolé pour ce dernier
le premier ça des qualités s'est montrée
vous voyez nous ne sommes pas totalement
isolée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le contenu